[Music]
chuck yes i've been looking forward to
this one uh-oh that's explainer video
okay what do you mean oh that's good
oh this this reveals your mixed emotions
about this yeah well you know i told you
it's always uh
it's always an adventure not not because
of what we talk about but
because you pick some pretty um out
there stuff like out there stuff so so
we're gonna this one's gonna be about um
id numbers see that's what i was talking
about and tracking numbers
that's what it
that's exactly what you're talking about
this is exactly what i'm saying you know
what i mean
okay and it's like hey man
listen
this is what i love about the explainers
it's like if you're at a cocktail party
and somebody says something and you're
like oh so boy
here we go and then you're stuck because
you're both sharing a drink and looking
at each other in that moment right right
then
when they tell you whatever it is you're
like oh wow oh right you know like it's
really it's terrifying and refreshing
all at the same time
okay
all right so let's look at social
security numbers
okay
uh so the format is what
uh three two four three two four
so
if that's the format
you can ask the very simple question
and and every
every working person in the united
states every citizen gets a social
security number yes
how many possible people
can those social security numbers cover
okay this is a very natural question
right of course it is will they run out
of social security numbers yeah it's
like will they run out of phone numbers
okay we'll get there that's the next
thing we're gonna do okay okay so so
with social security number you have
three digits and by the way it matters
for this calculation each of those
digits can be anywhere from zero to nine
the ten
numerals of our counting system okay
okay
zero through nine
the same with the second digit the third
and the the two middles and the four on
the right
so
for every
digit for every slot
in an id number and let's just
treat the case of pure counting numbers
for now for every slot
there are ten
times
as many slots as the previous one that
you counted
okay every slot there's ten times as
many slots as the previous one you just
got okay okay so
so
maybe i could have said that better but
if you have just
one
one set of digits to count people right
okay
the most you can count is ten that's if
someone agrees to be counted as zero
right exactly okay that's the most you
get that you get that sometimes you see
these sometimes you see the football
players and they're like zero you know
oh and they're and i'm just like okay
all right i don't know but they have
double zero which is different well
there's double zero you know what double
zero is
no it's a hundred
it's a hundred
okay double zero is because they don't
put three digits across their back all
right wait a minute guys here we go we
gotta go uh we got to go let's see this
is explainer inception
because
we're in an explainer but now we must go
inside another explainer
because seriously what do you mean it's
a hundred well well could well let me
put say it another way that is my
understanding because you can't put 100
on a jersey so they put two zeros i got
what you're saying so you start at zero
you go to 99 if you're 99 well then if
somebody wants to be 100 they got to be
double zero they got they're double zero
so that's what the double zero is is
what's as might as i understand it but
all right now take this pill so that we
can get out of this explainer and get
back to the other explainer for those of
you who have not seen the film inception
okay
this is it's kind of a uh
yeah it's a mind meld uh you got to get
inside the brain of the dream inside the
brain of the person who's dreaming
all right so
uh so so if
you got one digit if people agreed that
they could be numbered zero you can it
works for ten people right okay so now
you have two digits
so all you have to do
is count
until you run out of digits so you can
start with zero right and then you go up
to
99. there we go how many numbers is that
it's a hundred that's a hundred right
okay so with
two slots
it's ten times the previous one right
okay with three slots
you would start out zero zero zero zero
zero one zero zero two blah blah blah
blah zero one zero zero one one one two
one three one zero zero there two three
four and you do all of that you get up
to how high
a thousand
no oh nine ninety nine nine nine because
you only have three decimal places right
a thousand requires four that's not
allowed yet okay right you get up to 999
okay
plus the zeros you started with
so three decimal places does get you to
a thousand because you started with
zeros on that okay
all right so you can just keep doing
this and let's do this for the social
security number all right so the social
security numbers has there's four five
six seven eight
nine slots
nine slots right so if they're all nines
okay we have nine nines that's 999
million nine hundred and ninety nine
thousand three six nine yeah 999 million
999
999 right okay
now i add the if someone we're all
zeroes i don't know if anybody is but
let's imagine that
that gets it up to
how many
uh
which one more than 999 million
100 million
votes no one more that's 999 million and
one though no no no no it's we're at 999
a million 909 thousand 999 right okay
then right so we're at a billion now
billion there you go yeah we're at a
billion now and in honor of carl sagan
we shall say a billion billion
so
social security numbers can accommodate
a billion people
wow which
i mean and they all have to be
living
well so i don't know if they reuse
social security numbers of dead people
i just don't know i didn't check on that
but if they do that's fine because the
population in the united states is like
340 million so we have enough social
security numbers for three times
basically three times the population of
the united states right that's kind of
cool that's kind of cool yeah so so if
they run out because they they somehow
preserve the social security numbers of
dead people then they'd have to add a
digit
right so be it would be four digits two
digits then four digits and that will
give you ten times more
and that'll that'll take us we hope the
population doesn't ever get that high
right and we run out of resources now
you're in the thanos territory okay
where's thanos when you need them the
snappers fingers
to save us from ourselves
okay which movie is that from
that is um that's what marvel movie is
that it's avengers yeah
something end game end game game and
avengers end game well it's spread
across a couple of films actually so
okay so let's do it with phone numbers
okay okay so in the old way before we
move on yeah you sure you don't want to
offer the people your social security
[Laughter]
by the way i don't know if you remember
the guy who i don't forget the company
but he did a stunt where he went on
national tv and he was like this is my
social security number and my my uh
security company is so secure that i'm
letting you have because i could never
be hacked and of course they hacked him
and ruined a guy
okay
yeah you can always be here's the here's
a deep lesson for us all right you can
always be hacked by someone smarter than
you
there you go that's what it means when
the person is smarter than you that's it
okay right you can have well i'm an
expert hack protector and you hire me
and then i do and and i close all the
loops and everything that's good until
someone smarter than me comes along
right and and gets through it that's all
so
you need the single smartest hacker in
the world to protect you and then you're
good
absolutely except we're still getting
we're still giving birth to more people
i was going to say except that day will
never come
all right let's go back in the old days
of phone numbers where no one really
carried the
the area code
because area codes really
demarked area and you really didn't know
many people outside your area code and
if you did it was a special moment to
call long distance operator i'm calling
long distance right that's how old we
both are because we remember that let's
go back to the seven digits so seven
digits they can each be
well the lead digit can't be a zero but
let's ignore that for now let's assume
they each had ten digits so
seven of these
would be
99 million
is this right no no nine million nine
hundred ninety nine thousand nine
hundred ninety nine
got you okay that's that's seven digits
right
nine million nine hundred ninety nine
thousand nine hundred ninety nine that's
all full up so i worked pretty much
everywhere in the country
all you needed was seven digits because
there were no
cities or states that had
more than nine million people even new
york at that time the population yeah
was it that you needed nine million
people is it did you have nine million
phones nine million phones exactly
because households only had one phone
one phone right right right now you
might have had two phones because you
have a business phone at your office and
then one at home but that isn't that
funny i didn't even think you're
thinking of everybody i'm thinking
everybody has a number but no back then
you had a phone in your house
and and if you were on green acres
right town had one
had a phone
okay that's rough green acres a
television show from the 1960s so
we need
we need some subtext here so people can
keep track
of these references and it's still on tv
by the way
so nine million nine hundred ninety
thousand nine hundred nine yeah that's
basically ten million people and so then
uh when the total number of phones
started getting out of hand this
happened in new york city pretty early
okay uh
the city's population is 8 million but
everyone of course had an office phone
sometimes you had more than one office
phone and people getting multiple lines
in their own home and said we gotta we
don't want to stop this but we have to
fix it and so
they forced everyone in new york we were
among the first to do this to have to
dial 10 digits
to even call locally yeah okay the three
area codes
for manhattan manhattan and we added
seven one eight one eight and that was
basically for the outer boroughs but
still it just became this mix and so now
once you add an area code
you have three extra digits so you went
from
nine million nine hundred nine thousand
nine or nine to
ninety
million
i mean two nine yeah 99 billion
999 million
999 999 that's the 10 digits that's the
ten days okay so those ten digits if you
add the zero at the beginning which we
wouldn't but just to get it's a ballpark
number here we'll be getting 10 billion
phone numbers right
that's plenty
yeah for now well that's plenty for the
united states yeah okay so now the
united states has a plus one in front
okay was that north america i forgot
which that's the country code a country
code so now
in addition we've added an eleventh
digit that's right okay and country
codes don't only go to nine some
countries have two codes so they're 12
digits
oh my gosh
12 digits
that's a trillion
okay 999 billion 999 million 999 999
plus one is a trillion
so
we basically have
enough phone numbers for trillion phones
in the world
with with the 10 digits plus the country
code
and by the way if if you have sprint
none of them are getting reception
just
just let me know
okay
but wait so it's not just ids or phone
numbers how about a fedex
number
okay
okay okay you've probably sent many more
fedexes
than you own phones oh without a doubt
okay so fedex
has 12 digits
in it
okay
however i i think fedex can also have
letters in there yes they do okay
letters
so every time you hit a letter
you don't multiply by 10
you multiply by the total number of
letters available to you
which is 126. 26. so every letter slot
in an id code
you multiply whatever was going on up to
them not by 10 but by 26 damn
yes and so the number can get really big
really fast like airplane reservation
codes right those are six
right um
[Music]
there's six characters
and i think they can be either letters
or numbers it doesn't make a difference
does it make a difference they can
randomize okay which means each slot has
how many possibilities uh 26 plus 10
right 36 slots so it's 36 times 36 times
36 times 36 times 36 times 36. damn i
telling you now let me do that right
quick here yeah and here
and it doesn't make a difference because
uh no matter what you're not going to be
able to uh get the lady on the phone to
understand you
see
that's
okay and may i have your reservation
number yeah
okay so the reservation number i get so
36 to the sixth power is what that is i
get 2 billion 176 million 782 336. so
that's how many total possible reserve
billion reservation codes
are possible with those six and never
repeating okay but why not repeat them i
mean you know use a code from 10 years
ago who cares exactly right yeah right
yeah i mean
yeah they're not going to honor it
anyway
so so that's that's how you figure out
how many total
codes there are that's amazing
that's how you do that all right well
this
was super fun chuck that's all we have
time for all right all right
another star talk explainer chuck nice
always good to have you man always a
pleasure neil degrasse tyson keep
looking up
[Music]
you